great to talk with you um so i have a
ton of questions about the movie um i've
never spoken to you before i like
throwing some curveballs at the
beginning just to you know what the hell
um so i'm just curious if you could get
the financing to make anything you want
tomorrow what would you make and why
um
what would i make and why
anything do i have no restrictions
whatsoever yeah it's like a question
designed like in case you've had like a
script in the desk that you've just not
been able to get made you know what i
mean
many many many um
uh
there's a script that i wrote
one i was i would write it in the
evenings when i was um uh
directing battle of the bastards it was
season six
and as my wind down each day i would get
home and i would write the script and
because i wasn't writing it for anybody
it was just for me it could be
the worst script possible all that
mattered is that i wrote five pages a
day because i had to finish it within
the time frame of actually making better
the bastards
and it uh it's called the grid
and uh
it's about it's a time travel movie
because basically i hate time travel
movies and i don't believe in time
travel and so i decided that what better
thing to write about than something that
you absolutely categorically don't
believe in in an effort to try and find
a way to believe in time travel movies
and it's heavily influenced by as a
short film called legete by chris marker
which i think was used as an inspiration
for 12 monkeys
which i saw many years ago and i found
to be a phenomenal short film
and i've always wanted to make something
that was like an homage to that so i
would probably
go after something like that it shoots
in paris it's got two characters in it
doesn't cost much money
my dream
uh i would totally see this i'm a i'm a
sucker for time travel movies especially
for people
like like oh i'm a sucker for them i
really am it's just a genre uh
um it doesn't anyway i you know
hopefully by the way i just want to say
that uh i don't know how you did
anything but direct that episode in
terms of like
like the stress of um that episode must
have been so stressful to direct with
how much you had to do in it i don't
know how you were able to to do anything
else do you know what i mean
it it was it was weird it was a
it was like this it was this cathartic
process that would happen each evening i
would be
shooting in the day and all day i'd be
thinking about
when i get home you know
i've figured out how i'm going to do
that scene
um
i think it was just a you know it's a
it's like a deflection i don't have to
think about the stress of doing about
the bastards because i'm i'm focused on
what i'm going to make for dinner
obviously uh like everyone i think that
episode is incredible just want to thank
you for that episode thank you it's so
good um so what is it about end of the
world movies and television shows that
people love because it's a genre it's
almost like people romanticize the end
of the world and surviving in this
you know
uh in some way but i mean maybe i'm
digging too deep into this but it's just
something that i think people do uh what
do you think it is about that
i mean i
i do
it does seem to me like uh
it's that it's the classic what if
question right it's the
you kind of go well you know what could
imagine if i was the last person on
earth like what would i do how many how
many ice creams would i eat when would i
get sick of ice creams and then what
would i eat and like you know
there's there's something about that
that i think we all fantasize in some
way i don't know about the ice creams
but we all think about what it would be
like to be the last person on earth and
so
it's has an s aspect of wish fulfillment
it there's a nightmarish part to it as
well
um
and really
i can't think of anything more
both terrifying and potentially
conflicted about being the last person
and that makes for good drama and so i
think
there's a there's there's a lot of good
reasons to do a last man on earth uh or
last person on earth movie
uh how did this film actually happen for
you
like what was the genesis of how this
all came together
i was i was approached many many many
years ago probably about 15 years ago by
craig luck who was one of the writers on
the script uh
who had written a short film called bios
that he wanted to direct
and
he wanted advice and i gave him advice
and i introduced him to a bunch of
people that i had worked with previously
doing commercials and short films
and then
years later a very dear friend of mine
called evil powell who is a long time
kind of collaborator of mine we've
written many scripts together and
he gave me my break in uh
in uh uh commercials and he was ridley
scott and hugh hudson tony scott's
commercial producer and he was the line
producer and
duelist and alien and blade runner and
you know so somebody that i had a lot of
a lot of time for uh he came up to me
and said hey this young guy approached
me with this idea and we turned it into
a feature script i said what's it called
he said it's called bios it's written by
this guy called craig luck
and so suddenly it gone full circle and
here i was
reading this script um and i found it
you know it had a
it had an absence of some sentimentality
to it that i found very engaging and
each time i would read it i would be
surprised at the fact that i'd get a
lump in my throat towards the end
and i'm not a terribly
um
uh
i'm not a terribly sentimental person so
there's something
that
i kept finding my way back to the script
and so we decided to kind of develop it
and at some point we reached a
place where we thought okay we need to
actually get some
you know some producers of weight
involved and so we got kevin misha
and jack ratkee and robert zemeckis and
jackie levine who were part of image
movers involved and they took it to tom
hanks and he
said i like the script can we meet and
you know suddenly it was a real film
yeah i want to know what it's like the
night before you're going to listen
you've directed a lot of things and
you've worked with a lot of different
people tom hanks is like that next level
of so what is it like the night before
you're gonna meet with tom and are you
like in your head [ __ ] i really hope he
likes me
yeah i mean you know usually what i do
is i sit there and i try and figure out
what kind of socks i should wear
um because i i can't think about socks
and so i i kind of sit there and i say
you know should i put the jaws socks
that say bite me on or should i put the
or should i just keep it really simple i
should like you know what am i going to
do because that's the secret thing i'm
saying is in my socks and um
uh
uh
yeah i mean it's it's definitely it
would
meeting tom hanks was a was the first
time was super nerve-wracking because
i really hoped that he felt the same way
about the movie that i did i didn't know
anything beyond that he liked it and i
also didn't know
how real it was
so
i would have to say the
most frightening part of that was
sitting in the playtone
production company reception waiting to
have that meeting you know wondering
whether i'd put money in the meter of
the car or one like all the things that
you start thinking about again to
distract yourself from the fact that
you're about to go and meet this movie
star
the reality is is i met him and he was
lovely and we talked about stereos and
and typewriters and then he said i
really like your movie can i be in it
and uh and then i spent 10 minutes
pitching to him how i wanted to be him
to be in my movie and until i realized
he'd already said can i be in your movie
and then i was like shut up
and that was that
uh one of the things about tom obviously
he's he's a good director he's a
phenomenal actor like he can do
everything what is it like collaborating
with him on set when you have someone of
that caliber who's just so smart about
everything you know once you get past
the starstruckness of working with
somebody like that and you get into the
nitty-gritty in the trenches with them
the hope is that they're just like
anybody else
the reason that they're there is because
they're good at what they do and
the reason you're there is because in
theory you're also good at what you do
and you want to collaborate um so
it really was it was it was just it was
a it was a regular and very very
productive collaboration from the very
start
all the way through to the end there was
no there was nothing
it was unique in its lack of uniqueness
it was extremely well
uh uh uh
uh
you know not extremely it it was it was
just a pleasure it just you know it was
like working with someone that you've
really wanted to work with and they turn
out to be really good and you go oh my
god you guys are really good and then
you have this great relationship
for you know a couple of years um
and you know we're still in touch now
it's it's a you he's a joy to work with
one of the things i really like about
one of the many things i really like
about the film is there's no like
exposition dumps there is just like you
present information sort of casually
like you can pick up on it but it's
never him expl you know what i mean can
you sort of talk about that
well i i think
i think initially
you know it had one of those opening
sequences where the you know the the
outcomes that the gamma flare and it
goes through the space and it you cut to
the house and there's a little girl
watching tv and suddenly all the lights
go off like it did have all of that
stuff in its original uh in in its
infancy the script but as we got further
into it it became apparent that part of
the mystery of this character
was what happened to him and in a way if
he could be the one telling that story
and if we could do it very much as you
describe in drips and drabs
almost casually almost uh
not enough information
then that mystery becomes so much richer
and so
that became
a specific choice um you know i'm a huge
fan of french films which i always find
they kind of dump you right into the
middle of the story without any
explanation and you have to find your
way out and i really enjoy that i really
take pleasure in that and i wanted the
audience to work
um you know
we we
we had a version where we had a scroll
we had like we had different versions
and in the end i think it was a quite uh
kind of collective brave choice of
everybody involved it was like you know
what let's just not explain anything and
let's just start the movie and then
gradually let's bring people in when we
feel that the story cannot be continued
without that information
i think it really works the way you did
it um i love talking about about editing
because you know it's where it all comes
together um did you end up having like a
much longer cut did you end up with a
lot of deleted scenes how did it change
in the editing room
uh yeah yeah absolutely
we we shot a lot
there's a whole section
that ended up in the cutting room floor
that was about jeff finally coming into
contact with human beings and
how they're not what he expected and
certainly
not
what his father
finch had prepared him for
um
uh
but
as with any kind of uh uh movie you
you're finding it in multiple at
different stages you're finding the
movie again and again you're rewriting
the movie again and again
and when we got to post and we were in
the edit there was a point where i
realized that i knew we had reached the
end of the movie but we still had more
story to tell
and
and so i tried as
as much as i could to see if we could
accommodate it but
it wasn't
it was a bigger story than we had time
to tell in the time that we had left to
tell it
and
at some point we just had to make a
choice and
to me i believe the notion of kill your
darlings you know it was it was i loved
it i really liked what we did it was had
great actors in it had samara widely in
it it had
my wife alexis raymond was in it we had
skeet all right in it we had a load of
people in it and and and it was really
good it just
it wasn't the right ending for this
chapter of this story um and uh and
you know
had to let it go
oh she you're saying that that the stuff
that you cut basically is the end of the
like what could have been more of an end
of a movie
it could have been another third of a
movie probably yeah
wow um that's so i i have so many
follow-up questions to that i can't
imagine what it's like
i can't imagine though what it's like
telling your wife listen you were great
but you're not going to be in the movie
yeah i didn't go home for a while it was
good
um listen uh before i run out of time
with you um uh obviously i'm a fan of
your work on game of thrones and i know
you can't talk about the new series but
i do i do want to ask you if you don't
mind um
uh what did you take away
working on game of thrones that maybe
you wanted to bring with you into the
new series um without because i don't
want to obviously you know um
i know you don't probably want to talk
too much about it but i am curious just
maybe what you learned and how that you
brought that with you
i learned two different ideas if i ain't
broken don't fix it
um
but also
every story has a natural evolution
and we would be remiss
if we weren't to explore the evolution
of this story um and there's an
opportunity there that
we would be foolish not to take and so
hopefully you know that's what we're
doing
um i'm obviously very excited um
my last thing for you uh how has
technology helped you in terms of
directing on finch and directing on uh
game of thrones on everything because
it's amazing to me what technology has
done especially the last few years
i think technology uh has been
instrumental in
my learning curve of how to make films i
think whereas
in the most simplest form
whereas
it used to be that
if it if
everything had to work in the frame
or
i had to go again and do the do another
take
now i've realized that
you get things to a certain place and
then you realize you have the ability
and the technology to manipulate the
image
to get you to that perfection
and
what that means is you can keep striving
for that perfection but you can also
stop and try something else you you can
give yourselves options
in a way that you couldn't before
and
it's a different discipline knowing when
to stop you know it's a
but i i do feel like
technology has opened up the possibility
to
many more people to make films
but also
[Music]
it flexes a new muscle that we have
which is
learning that less is more
on that note i really want to say
congrats on finch hopefully one day i
can see that footage that was cut and on
that note because i really would like to
see it and on that note
i wish you nothing but the best
you